okay hi everybody welcome we're gonna
get started
ethnicity race to migration in American
Studies it's just so nice to see such a
full room the guests that we're about to
introduce just spent an hour in a
graduate seminar that I taught and I
just have to say by way of thanks to the
Yale Center for the Study of race
indigeneity and transnational migration
to have a center units like American
Studies at the city race and migration
they can just bring such committed
collaborative scholars into like the
presence and as a site of graduate
education I'm so so grateful for so I
just want to thank Steven pity Matthew
tannic Oh Nicole Edwards and ratm for
sustaining spaces like this I'm really
really grateful it was just such a rich
and generative discussion I'll just we
have the next event in the series will
be next Tuesday it's gonna be in the
evening at six o'clock in wlh 309 and
it'll be with Professor Christina
Heatherton who's a colleague of mine
who's at Barnard College she's going to
be giving a wonderful talk about the
artist Elizabeth Catlett and her
emergence as a kind of site of black
feminist internationalism through her
experiences and training in Mexico in
particular so that's next Tuesday at six
o'clock I'll just quickly introduce our
speakers then turn over to my colleague
Lisa Lowe oh and I'll also just mention
this quickly because it connects to our
panel tomorrow night at six o'clock
there's a plenary titled imagining a
future of public abundance which is
really about how we reimagine public our
commitments to one another what we
imagine the state for ourselves to do
after many decades of privatization
austerity so it's at six o'clock at
Dwight Hall from 6 to 7:30 I'm gonna
just pass this around so now we turn to
our panel and I'll just introduce them
quickly and just say just one very quick
thing about connections Monica Ruka is
an assistant professor of American
Studies and affiliated with women's
gender and sexuality studies at Barnard
College his work centers a critique of
imperialism with a
focused on anti-racism and indigenous
decolonization and he's the author of a
truly wonderful and breathtaking book
empires tracts indigenous indigenous
nations Chinese workers and the
Transcontinental Railroad published by
University of California Press
Jody Byrd is a citizen of the Chickasaw
Nation of Oklahoma an associate
professor of English and Gender Women's
Studies at the University of Illinois
urbana-champaign she's also a faculty
affiliate there of the National Center
for supercomputing applications her work
spans critical Indigenous Studies and
governance critical technology studies
indigenous feminism's and sexualities
she's the author of a deeply influential
monograph the transit of Empire
indigenous critiques of colonialism and
co-editor with Alyosha Goldstein Jody
Malamud and Chandan Reddy of an issue of
social text titled economies of
dispossession indigent indigeneity race
and capitalism and social text which is
published here hosted a conference about
that so I also just feel grateful that
we're kind of back in relation for that
project as well and finally alyosha
goldstein professor of American Studies
at the University of New Mexico
Goldstein's the author of poverty in
common the politics of Community Action
during the American Century and editor
of formations of United States
colonialism and does work on
globalization neoliberalism and social
movements I had an absolutely gorgeous
slide of all of their books together
which we can imagine
that's why we do this together and even
in just putting the slide it made me
think about the relationships we can
trace in this work there's something
just deeply important about the
collective investment in shared
intellectual goals and we really saw it
in this time in our graduate students
within the seminar where none of this
work is possible to be done at an
individual site of knowledge production
people are deeply deeply reliant on the
kinds of insights they're producing
together and I realize as they were
talking that this is very much about the
very remaking of knowledge the
intellectual organization of the
University often reproduces and
naturalizes all of the severance is dis
possessions and disturbed relationality
z' of capitalism and liberalism so land
from labor racial domination from
colonialism etc so this is work that
very consciously interrogate the terms
of those separations it constantly
transgresses undermines and refuses the
conventions of liberalism market
economies everything becomes open for
contestation and re-imagination
ourselves included I'll just turn now to
introduce my colleague Lisa Lowe who's
moderating the panel but I want to just
say when you read all these together one
through line you see is references to
Professor Lowe scholarship and not just
as a performative citation but because
professor Lowe's work is doing
particular things in all of their
analysis and shared commitments so it's
an honor to be there with them and also
to share this with you and I'll
introduce Lisa Lowe now thank you
welcome everybody as professor hosting
was saying this is really an honor and a
privilege to hear from these three
scholars today who are very much
thinking with one another but also
thinking with all of us in my graduate
seminar last semester we read their work
semester before and I think all of you
appreciate what it means to have them
here in discussion so I'd like to start
by just inviting each of them to speak
Jen
about the way in which their work as
individual scholars in their monographs
but also their collaborations and their
practices as activists and intellectuals
has placed the study of settler
colonialism in relation to racial
capitalism and that might involve for
each of them I'm piecing a little bit
what we understand those those terms to
mean and what it means particularly for
them working in certain historical
periods and on certain paradigms so why
don't we go in this order I'm beginning
with you want to begin with manu okay i
think i'm so happy to be here sitting
with some of my favorite intellectuals
not only in the front of the room but
throughout the entire room can you hear
me in the back yeah all right so let me
just begin so I think to just go off of
something that you put on the table it's
the work to think through these concepts
and think across what are may be useful
but also arbitrary divisions or divides
and there are gaps so I work in archive
so there are gaps in the work that's
produced that are actually not
necessarily there in the archives so for
example in the book in empires tracks
there's a dialogue between railroad
corporate officials and military
officials they're talking back and forth
about resources and a shared common
effort in building a railroad and
occupying indigenous lands and they're
distinct subfields of US history
there's US corporate history and there's
US military history that have read one
part of this dialogue and so when you're
in the archive you you see the the
letters back and forth and yet the
histories have been written only using
one side one one part of that dialogue
right so that's just one specific
example of those arbitrary maybe
sometimes useful distinctions that I
think we're all trying to think against
and push against so to take up the term
settler colonialism and racial
capitalism for me I wrestled with these
terms as terms that give us
access to specificity and precision
which are useful I think but also as
terms that can push into exceptionalism
which is not so useful so wanting to
push against those Exceptionalist
dimensions of the thought so
just some brief thoughts that come to
mind with defining what's specific about
settler colonialism what's specific
about racial capitalism so the oxford
english dictionary defines colonialism
as colony the colonization by settlement
which if we're going to take
colonization by settlement to be
colonialism then it raises a question
about what's distinct about settler
colonialism it almost raises a certain
circularity about it
I'm not a philologist so you know we
don't need to be bound to definitions
but then there are other ways that the
field gets proposed that the field
announces itself the work on settler
colonialism is at work about Anglophone
settler colonies is at work about the
British Empire the Commonwealth plus the
United States so for example the history
replenishing the earth by James Bell
each is a work about settler colonialism
and Anglophone settler colonies leaving
out Ireland which to me is interesting
an interesting illusion but you know so
if we forget that historical precedent
of fact Anglophone stellar colonies is
this what settler colonialism is Robin
DG Kelley has pointed out in an
engagement with traces of history
Patrick Wolf's last book that the field
in many ways leaves out Africa the
continent and different sites by
different empires we could think of
Algeria we can think of course of South
Africa we can think of Kenya and you
know it leaves out not only these
histories this space the geography of
Africa it also leaves out the political
truth the political you know seemingly
important fact that these are sites in
some places where settler colonialism
failed or settler colonialism was
defeated and then you know for us living
let's say in North America what lessons
can be drawn from the defeat of settler
colonialism in southern Africa so the
field you know proposes and defines
itself in certain ways that leave
potentially very important questions off
the table for us
racial capitalism is a term that I as
that I use that some you know really
central to my thinking but there are
certain challenges that arise with
racial capitalism you know the term
itself I think is it reminds us all that
capitalism always has proceeded on a
racial basis and yet we know as
especially as big foundations give big
money to study of racial capitalism it's
almost as if there's an idea that
there's a kind of racial capitalism but
there's another kind of capitalism that
racial capitalism is a particular kind
of capitalism that there's another kind
of capitalism we could imagine that's
not racial capitalism but to go back to
the original point of racial capitalism
is just the fact that all capitalism has
proceeded on a racial basis or through
racial differentiation than what
distinguishes racial capitalism from
capitalism analytically as we use the
term so there's a kind of redundancy in
the term similar to sell there
colonialism colonization by a settlement
the accumulation of capital the racial
differentiation another challenge for me
with racial capitalism at this point in
the conversation is taking race as a
point of origin for the analysis whether
we're talking about historical point of
origin or a theoretical or structural
point of our origin race as assumed as
an explanation or a cause rather than
race is what is produced or races what
needs to be explained
so in black Marxism race appears in
quotation marks and in Cedric Robinson's
writing there and elsewhere this is
something that you know in the work of
Ruthie Gilmore I find a great and very
productive challenge the insistence that
we need to always remember that race is
what we need to explain races is is a
fiction with very real concrete effects
but we need to explain race we don't
need to proceed from it from an
understanding that race is is gives us
the answer
Stuart Hall of course is another has
produced another body of work that helps
us to think through these questions
and in our moment there's a way I've I
sense it feels that in many ways we on
the anti-racist side we've actually
slipped into re biologic re biology
zhing race through ancestry through
inheritance taking race as a biological
category not like the crazy you Genesis
but you know it's it's almost slipped
into the conversation slipped into the
analysis rather than taking race as a
feature of political economy which i
think is actually the lesson i take from
the idea of racial capitalism to stop me
if i'm going on to you can talk for a
long time but um so so thinking about
whether colonialism and racial
capitalism together for me brings me to
think about imperialism as a category
imperialism to think about how race is
produced to think about distinct modes
of colonialism that are in relation
productive and otherwise with each other
and to think about questions of defeat
and pushing and winning victories so one
way and imperialism for me is is a
conjuncture or category it's always it
exists in different ways in different
moments so even to think about the term
stellar colonialism and racial
capitalism I'm increasingly learning to
think conjuncture ly about these terms
so for example you know when we talk
about settler colonialism many people
cite Patrick wolf and some core
formulations and core pieces that he
wrote he was writing and thinking about
questions in very specific historical
moment in political moment in Australia
so as a question for us as his readers
what was his moment what was what what
was on the table politically that led
him to ask these questions and to to you
know arrive at these provisional answers
through this idea of settler colonialism
another through line we could look to is
how nanny K Trask again with the idea of
southern colonialism in a different
place in a different time in Hawaii what
was it that was happening in that place
in time that led her to propose these
ways of thinking about settler
colonialism and with what's with racial
capitalism of course we could think
about Cedric Robinson easy as
was working through the ideas of black
Marxism the core concepts what was
happening and what was he responding to
in his political moment and then you
know in our own moment what connects our
moment to those specific places and
times as we engage those those ideas as
we cite those works what is resonant in
our moment what political questions are
on the table that we need to answer that
they were grappling with and what is
different you know I think those are
actually it feels to me important sets
of questions to to answer in thinking
about the relationship between these
terms so there are two people I want to
kind of briefly hopefully not hopefully
briefly and not too long but kind of
engage in in their work that's been
providing the answers the keys to think
through these questions one is ageism
odd and the other is Gerald Horne and
I've been working and thinking a lot
with his to me an incredible essay by a
dozen mud called Iraq Afghanistan and
the imperialism of our times which was
written after 9/11 is written after the
u.s. criminal invasion of Iraq and in
this essay he's assessing what is the
unique shape and nature of imperialism
in that moment of the of the George W
Bush administration in the United States
after the US had launched this invasion
and what had changed and what were the
historical models to draw upon in
earlier times and a mod proposes this
idea of something he calls imperial
sovereignty which he's developed in
later essays and interviews drawing on
the authorization for the use of the
minimum use of force act that US
Congress passed in days after I think
unanimously in the days after 9/11 and
so with this idea of imperial
sovereignty as I read this essay and I'm
thinking about our own moment and what's
on the table politically now it raises
these questions what does what do these
ideas of settler colonialism and racial
capitalism help us understand about our
moment
Imperial sovereignty in this moment so I
want to just briefly talk about some of
these points that Ahmad is is trying to
track out so he's tracking out in the
early years of a war on terror a
doctrine of limited sovereignty that he
says is emerging as a major component in
US policy with vast implications for
what he calls a new Imperial
constitutionalism and this is applied
not only to third-world countries but
even selectively to Europe's abilities
to pass laws for itself so every example
if you remember there was a rendition of
someone from the streets of Genoa in
Italy who was just taken by US
intelligence forces and then rendered to
some black site so even in European
territory raises these questions about
what is a sovereign control of these
countries the u.s. 'mad rights claims a
sovereign act sovereign right to act in
its own interests which had caused
offense while flouting the sovereignty
of others so that the sovereignty of the
imperial state seems boundless so this
is one aspect of what he's calling
imperial sovereignty
well we're witnessing he rights is the
making of an imperial sovereignty
claimed for itself by state wishes at
once the state of a nation as well as a
globalized state of contemporary
capitalism so there's something distinct
about the nature of capitalism at this
time the u.s. irrigates to itself a
lemon limitless sovereign tree which is
arbitrary by nature and can only exist
in so far as its might is so superior to
that of all others that it's action
would necessarily go unchallenged by
other components of the global state
system however resentful they might be
otherwise so European Union IMF WTO
World Bank the u.s. is willing the
International Court willing to go
against these in its own interests this
globalized and punctual policy of
military interventions has mystified
those on the left for whom contemporary
capitalism is system is a system
essentially of transactions among the
advanced countries and for whom the
third world is largely irrelevant due to
the meagerness of its share in world
production and trade however Ahmad
continues even as a third-rate general
would know it's on the flanks that the
center is secured no flanks no sin
so the US has always sought to had
Gemini's the whole of the Tri
continental Imperial Rome in Asia Africa
and Latin America sua samin Appa lies
its vast strategic resources and thwart
its revolutionary potentials in a
permanent counter-revolution consolidate
its dominant position within the one
event the one of advance capitalism
itself so here I think that long quote
hopeful ad and read it too fast but I
think there's a bridge to indigenous
studies here you know the this concept
of imperial sovereignty raises the
question of what exactly is us
sovereignty let's say over what the u.s.
calls its homeland in empires tracts I
try to think through this through a
concept of Councillors sovereignty that
the u.s. declares its sovereignty always
in reaction to you know collective life
that exists a mod continues with some to
me really interesting this is you know
after the invasion of Iraq really
interesting notes and insights on
settler colonialism itself so this is
the reason why I want to set this up
with his essay he writes there's a sharp
contrast between different kinds of
colonialism as for example between
settler colonialism which succeeded in
the Americas and Australia but failed in
Africa and the so called colonies which
were occupied administered and exploited
by bourgeoisie so external to them that
they never put down their roots and
conquered lands some of the white
settlements and the temperate zones made
a transition to advanced capitalism
notably North America and to an extent
Australia and New Zealand but others did
not
he writes as in South America none of
the occupy but unsettled colonies did
not even India which had fairly advanced
levels of mercantile capital as well as
sophisticated pre-industrial
manufacturers at the moment of
colonization and this would stand for
for China as well as for the major
African empires songa Congo Ashanti
Ahmad continues much capital and
technology was transferred to the
settler colonies but very little to the
unsettled ones so there's something
about the nature of capital and
development that settler colonialism
distinguishes right between other forms
of colonialism and he ends the settler
colonies which made the
capitalist transition are marked by the
dominance of industry over agriculture
and they have a demographic balance in
which the employed greatly outnumber the
unemployed and those which did not make
that transition the unemployed and
indifferently employed tend to exceed
the employed sections of the working
class so I think there's a lot that's
really concrete telling us about region
the relationship of the countryside to
the city the relationship of
agricultural labor to industrial labor
the relationship of employed to the
unemployed there's a lot that he's
actually drawing out from this
distinction of settler colonialism and
other forms of colonialism that we that
we could say or not settler colonialism
so I think there's a lot of value if we
want to be precise
what is settler colonialism what's its
relationship to capitalism and how does
this help us understand the nature of
imperialism in different historical
moments the other person I want to just
draw briefly is Gerald Horne who's been
thinking about and proposing that we
think about cellular colonialism as a
form of class collaboration and one way
I think this is for me really productive
is that it moves our attention away from
it routes our attention away from a
divide between settlers and natives
which is you know just it's divided
where we're kind of we're focused a lot
on discussing the the distinctions
between these identities it it draws our
attention away from that which maybe we
could link to the assumption of race as
a point of origin and instead it moves
us into a focus on land moves us to a
focus on labor so Horne argues that
cellular colonialism is a form of class
collaboration by offering the
possibility of free land by offering the
possibility of owning labor by offering
the possibility of being a slave owner
or or an industrialist plantation owner
so he's pointing to an alliance between
a yeoman farmer a plantation owner and
industrial capitalists and we can see we
can map out a history of finance in this
class alliance that that ultimately you
know removes the planter the plan TOC
recei from this equation it settles on
the balance between a yeoman farmer and
industrialist there's a link here I
think to do boy
not only in black reconstruction where
he's mapping out that the end of that
triadic relationship but also in his
essay the African roots of war which is
explaining an analysis of imperialism
and the African roots of war Du Bois has
this concept of the dividends of
whiteness so I think there's a
connection here maybe with the dividends
of whiteness and this idea of settler
colonialism is classic collaboration
dividends is different than the wages of
whiteness which is the familiar term
from black reconstruction think about
the difference between wages which is
what a worker which is what a clappa
capitalist gives to a worker for
exploiting them and dividends which is
what an investor receives you know for
their investment so settler colonialism
in horns analysis diffuses class
struggles seller colonialism can give us
one ask answer to the question of why
hasn't there been a socialist party a
socialist movement of that's captured
state power in the United States and one
thing I think both the Ahmad and Horne
can help us do is move from a focus on
ontology or focus on race as the
beginning of analysis to focus on
organization and consciousness so part
of the question that's at the forefront
of my mind recently is what feels like
an imperative to D biologies whiteness
in our analysis and in our politics
understanding white as a political color
not white is a biological category
that's defined by race or inheritance so
what would it mean for us to think about
white organization what is Oh is there a
distinct white organization what are
those forms of organization what is a
white consciousness and what does that
consciousness look like how do we
understand it and critique it and maybe
we could look to for me these are just
very provisional notes linking ideas of
normativity with counter-revolutionary
reaction as Ahmad said a permanent
counter-revolution I'll leave it there
for now thank you
okay I'll try to be brief thinking about
this question about what how my work
encounters settler colonialism and
colonization or racial capitalism I
think I've been thinking about this for
a little and I'm incredibly you know
excited to be here with Manu and Alyosha
in my head I have chundan ready and Jody
Mohammed and Juliana who piggies and a
host of other people who have been
really instrumental I think over the
years of engaging and helping me put
forward and say your work I mean there's
so much that is
everything happens collaboratively and
thinking with and through I think I
transit was a is is it is a hard book
for me to think about now it because at
the time I wrote it I was coming from
post-colonial theory and it was at a
moment before we turned to settler
colonialism as a way to talk about the
United States and it was written out of
a frustration in those conversations
that were coming from post-colonial
studies about why the continent why the
United States why Mexico Central and
South America work and the Caribbean
well the Caribbean gets brought in in
interesting ways by indigenous peoples
were vacated as having any presence in
the conversation and so the way I've
tried to fix that was to spatialize
slightly racialization and colonization
right to pry them apart just slightly to
help us get at the investments that were
part of what we were calling at that
point liberal multiculturalism it's such
a weird thing to bring into the world or
right now because we're here in the the
return of whites appropriate and it's
not a return the reveal of white
supremacy that's been there all along
right but at the but at those moments
there was there was a certain way in
which we were understanding the the
smooth curve of progress within the
United States that it seemed that the
more we could incorporate people into
the system the more rights that were
given the more presence that was given
the more legibility visibility all of
these things that we would somehow end
up in a better place right and as it as
a citizen of the Chickasaw Nation
who's my I'm gonna position myself
historically I think just because it'll
show some of the stakes of the work
right my great-great grand uncle was
governor of the Chickasaw Nation in the
1890s he worked very hard as part of the
pole pack party to resist allotment he
was three months old at removal he was
born in Holly Springs Mississippi he was
removed and in our family went with over
a hundred and thirty slaves to Indian
Territory so he his ability to be
governor and be part of the ruling
family was contingent upon black slavery
and this is a conversation that has not
yet really fully been explored within
the Chickasaw Nation as its within its
historical consequences the Cherokee
Nation occasionally has accountings with
this but it is a responsibility of an
entanglement that as I think at the
heart of how we get to the complexities
of what colonialism and slavery brought
in homelands for us right so how do we
hold racialization and colonization were
Chickasaws are losing our lands are
racialized in that form and our also
function as sovereign nations that are
participating in racialization and
slavery right and then how do we think
about you know what an indigenous
responsibilities are in this and then
how we think about the complicities of
everyone I was at the time writing this
like it was in the early 2000s you know
the settler emerged in various
conversations Manya just traced a couple
of genealogies for it in post-colonial
studies there was a course work that was
being done in Canada talking about you
know Margaret Atwood as a settler and
and you know post-colonial writer there
was you know in in out Aotearoa New
Zealand hosts of different ways that
these questions were being framed
that frankly always centered the white
settler right always centered the white
settler and so it was it was it was some
frustration that I was trying to find a
way to pry that apart to sort of
disaggregate whiteness with settlement
in order to understand the United States
potentially and the Caribbean as
something slightly different I
as having a different trajectory of that
would account for us and Peary ilysm
that grew out of the colonization and
the United States can only do what it
does because it dominates indigenous
peoples and indigenous lands it's an
ongoing relationship it's one that is
never finished
and it's contingent right it depends
upon us naturalizing the idea that there
are 50 states right that these are
borders that are absolutely secure and
that are not contingent upon treaties
negotiated with every single community
that makes this up so so there was that
element and then it was that the force
of of presence is not necessarily and
primarily white settlers right there's
and that's why I went and turned to
canoe brathwaite and it's it's in
thinking about him and his recent
passing and understanding the stakes of
what he's brought to indigenous studies
the scale of insights that he brought
for us thinking about the category of
arriving to have a possibility of a way
of understanding forced removals as
being brought into relationship to
histories of colonialism genocide
slavery how do we actually understand
and undo or even repair a colonial
history that's built out of not an agent
of settler who gets to take his
sovereignty everywhere as somebody like
Lorenzo Vera Cheney might say but really
actually through the work in labor of
bodies that aren't even allowed to have
agency of their own right and how do we
how do we then also imagine what justice
could possibly be in that configuration
with everyone forced into violence's and
conscripted into into a relationship
that is counterproductive to survival
for everyone right for the planet -
we're looking at these scales getting
bigger and bigger they always have been
but I think you know as we are in our
contemporary moment we are seeing the
planets response to us in and to the
scales of what what calling racial
capitalism or colonial capitalism or and
there's many ways that we're trying to
triangulate or not even triangulate come
at it from multiple multiple angles that
what it is that are what we've produced
and so that was that was that was at
least the starting point in this I think
I came to racial capitalism
interestingly through getting to meet
Jody Muhammad and having her say I think
it would be really amazing to see you
read Cedric Robinson and nice because I
and I was like you guys are familiar
with it but he she's like I really love
to see you sit down and actually take
talk to that through indigenous studies
and and in some ways that became the the
framework for economies of dispossession
and you know taking up that that wish to
to bring these things into conversation
in a more sustained way and and and so I
it was it was it was through Jody and
and and and it was through you know
Jody's work that I that I'm starting to
really appreciate how how we can
understand capitalism through its anti
relationality
and its anti relational form as the
actual mode of its relationship right
she gets that through Ruthie Gilmore and
so in that conversation with her with
chundan thinking about you know his work
in freedom with violence just this kind
of continual repetition of a frontier
metaphor for this progressive
incorporation of peoples and the
horizons of of both being oppressed and
then liberated right this hothouse that
maybe Marx might call it of progression
from savagery to civilization that this
this that this entire system is giving
us you know a way to hold both
capitalism as its anti relational form
colonialism as as as its own relational
form and we can talk about how we might
want to name that form and then how we
get to even a temper allottee within
this and as always the concern for me is
how indigenous peoples fall out of even
the conversation
settler colonialism it's it's a kind
it's almost an in my my newest book work
is to think about why it is that there's
a consonant vacating of the urgency of
indigeneity at the at every turn no
matter what is going on whether you know
it's Elizabeth Warren or it's both so
attend
there's always an argument as to why
it's so small that it shouldn't matter
and can scale of what everyone is facing
in the world so there's a minimization
disappearance of vanishing indigenous
women and particularly go missing and
constantly disappeared in this and so it
so the challenge is always how to hold
what Indigenous Studies brings to the
conversation of understanding capitalism
racialization colonization without
either falling into anti it falling into
disappearing them completely or you know
ending up doing some form of what I Code
a might called romantic anti capitalism
right yeah there's so much more I want
to say but I also want to get to alia
should and I want us to come back to
thinking about all the questions that
sort of extend from that so I'm gonna be
I'll pause here yeah well it's an honor
to be here with you all and I'm just so
grateful to Lisa and Dan for the
invitation and to be likewise with some
of my favorite people um so I'm gonna be
I think pretty short because I would
like to kind of get to the broader
discussion but I just want to pick up on
a couple of the themes that have come up
so far and I guess maybe put out for
kind of further discussion returning to
this thinking about this relationship
between racial capitalism and settler
colonialism within a broader framework
of kind of the Imperial imperialism to
begin by saying a little bit about this
notion of ongoing right because one of
the think the one of the ways in which
now discussions around settler
colonialism are framed are with a kind
of the phrase or the kind of trope of
saying ongoing settler colonialism which
I think comes from Anna
pulse understandable I think is
something but my own impulse in terms of
something coming to some of the work
that I've done to make the argument
counter to this sort of historical
conclusion the notion of foundations the
notion of somehow a previous historical
moment that has come and gone
that in fact colonialism is something
that is ongoing but I think there's a
gap between this notion of ongoing and
this sort of idea of foundation there's
something that actually is profoundly
unsatisfying about that phrase in the
way it circulates now and I think that
one of the reasons is because it doesn't
actually contain with contend with the
historicity the substantive materiality
of what it means to be ongoing right it
flattens there's a notion that somehow
we've now recognized that there's this
thing called colonialism it's yes this
is not a moment in the United States
past this is only I mean I'm not saying
everybody says this in certain kind of
conversations there's this this is
something we now acknowledge and we by
this phrase ongoing settler colonialism
and so I think that the problem part of
the problem and part of the way in which
actually putting some substantively in
conversation this notion of racial
capitalism and settler colonialism
together in grappling with what that
ongoing might mean is the kind of
profound way in which both of these are
formations that are historical that are
that means specific things differently
at different moments and that come to
mean something very specific in the
present and so one of the ways I think
that it's possible to kind of get to
those questions is through an analysis
of social reproduction and I think
there's both to some of the things that
have come up
may be next room a slightly different
angle gets to this question of what
ongoing is that if you think of the
there kind of the framework of social
reproduction you're forced to actually
have to think about how is how are these
relations reproduced right now what and
what ways are the sort of dynamics of
power of subordination of value being
kind of staged and in that staging I
mean it goes to I think also something
that's really important which is the
ongoing may also then do what some of
the critiques I think that have been
leveled at Patrick wolf is to say
ongoing seems to imply an infinite 'no
sit basically reaffirms the settler
claim to permanence and so if you look
at social reproduction instead as a way
of thinking about what ongoing means it
actually means that it's hardly on go
it's not ongoing in any sort of
permanent sense it's always in flux it's
always open to contestation it's I mean
I think of Stuart Hall's you know the
ways of and you know there's no
guarantee that things are put back
together in the same way and I think
that's a profoundly important point both
in terms of thinking about contestation
about realizing that conditions that
seem permanent or not but it's also an
important to realize that in speaking
about something which we might now
recognize hopefully we recognize them or
we as weeds are problematic formation
there but um the that the the thing
called the United States is not
something that is self-evident there's
not something that is actually ongoing
it is something that is constantly being
reproduced in its very heterogeneity in
ways that again seek to naturalize to
take its given that formation so so I
think that part of the way and thinking
about capitalism as itself historically
emerging alongside in concert with
colonization that historically you know
the forms of modern notions of modern
race racialization that all of these
coincide is not necessarily to provide
again like what Monty was talking about
to presume that these things are
explanatory mechanisms that we read
forward but instead to really see the
way that these are a set of dynamics
that are recreated and given meaning in
specific ways at particular conjunctures
and so so I would just say one more
small thing before ending with so the
book that I'm finishing right now tries
to do some of the things that we just
said bye-bye really framing the us as
this sort of predatory assembly that's
we just to say it is not something that
pre-exists nor does it exist in any
coherent fashion other than the ways in
which it naturalized and normalizes
itself as such so that I mean and this
goes in the introduction to the
formations of United States colonialism
is a piece of open with talking about
the sort of the heterogeneity just of
the geopolitical sense of unincorporated
territories territories protectorates
you know the very the Colonia is just
all the sort of multiplicities that
coexist that somehow they're kind of
spaces of native sovereignty that are
that are still presumed to be subsumed
still presumed to be domestic dependent
nations that in fact don't that's
already something that's presupposed but
in fact never accepted that's I mean
most you know so to take that seriously
and think about actually the the kind of
ongoing history that is a history of the
United States as a nation-state
that can't be read from within the
history of the United States but has to
be read from multiple vantage points to
see the way in which it's produced
through the active appropriation and
subordination of people's through things
like slavery through racialization the
various forms of devaluation through the
appropriation of land that is never
final that is always ongoing and
contested so I think that's one
potential way I hope at least in the
book that I'm trying to get to things
like the verge OD was talking about like
how to how you could talk about
something like settler colonization in
ways that don't just reset it recenter
white folks again tell the story of like
you know the ways in which you know as
mano mentioned they're replenishing the
earth today this sort of these
narratives of conquests that kind of
have their own teleology z-- that always
end up talking about white people again
I'm talking about colonizers that I
think is sort of part of the task and I
think actually thinking capitalism as a
historical formation that rooted in
particular
forms of wage labor and land theft that
coincides directly and work together but
don't become the same thing thinking
these things together gives us a new way
to ask new questions and also to
actually I think you know fundamentally
see that our task you know the notion of
like decolonization it's another phrase
that terms aren't everything's getting
decolonized now so so I would say you
can't be colonize in the United States
the abolition of the United States is
decolonization the United States can
never be you can't decolonize
institutions that are themselves the
effects and are reproduced through the
processes of colonization and capitalist
exploitation it's only through their
abolition that we get to something we've
had actually call decolonization ilysm
empire is all three of these very rich
collaborative thinkers are very much
committed to D familiarizing terms and
concepts and situating them in material
and historical context and also thinking
in a relational way so whether we're I
mean - very rich comments about the ways
in which settler colonialism as a form
of white class collaboration can be
traced not only in the settlement of the
United States but within US imperialism
- Jodie's very moving statement about
the continued and repetitive erasure of
indigenous people and indigenous history
even as settler colonialism is recited
and Alyosha's work here and what he's
just described and in his forthcoming
book but also in
his writings looking at the ways in
which the u.s. colonial present is
precisely this predatory assemblage of
settlement extraction racial slavery
overseas Empire configured in different
historical moments together
so I guess to open discussion I wanted
to just ask each of you to talk about
this matter of configuration I mean I
think Jodi was getting at this with your
discussion of your your family the ways
in which these things are not isolated
all the the histories of indigenous
people and the history of settler
violence is not in a different temporal
or is configured with racial slavery in
in the history you're describing the the
the seizure of land in the building of
the railroads is coterminous with the
displacement and use of immigrant labor
and so forth so I wonder if you could
all talk about the difficulties of
conceptualizing entanglement
relationality and configuration and the
ramifications for struggling against
this u.s. colonial present is there a
way for example that rather than in the
analysis of these forms of extraction
slavery and Empire maybe it's in the
counter struggles against it that we
actually see ways of conceiving these
what many calls in empires tracks the
differentiated unity of capitalism and
Empire so do you have thoughts about
that
what just say something initially which
is so I'm actually thinking a little bit
we talked a bit about the sort of the
notion of I'm gonna fold this into one
of the other they talk about but just to
say but the question of land acknowledge
yes why don't you talk um because so we
we were speaking but we had a little
discussion before about the way in which
land acknowledgments operate these days
yes sure so thank you see teamwork it's
all about collaboration so as we're
talking about this we went and looked to
see well what does Yale do in these ways
and it's interesting to see that they do
in fact have formal guidelines for
providing land acknowledgments and you
know so as that which they describe
those words of recognition and thanks
frequently open events found on and our
written events today but and so they say
the this is their provided paragraph
that's a model it says yale university
acknowledges of indigenous peoples and
nations including the mohegan emotion
talk at peak what eastern Pequot chaga
shot to coke golden he'll pasa colette
PAGASA Niantic and clooney epic an other
end gong qin speaking peoples have
stewarded through generations the lands
and waterways of what is now the state
of connecticut we honor and respect the
enduring relationship that exists
between these peoples and nations and
this land so one of the things that we
were so so this in talking about like
what a land acknowledgement might that
this the way in which this now
circulates because certainly in the
united states may be different than
Canada there's a been a kind of a
somewhat a turn to institutions like
Yale and other universities including
land acknowledgments having this now
what is now become well like in Canada
are largely perfunctory means to
especially include it on official
guidelines that allows something like an
ignore
been of the past in order to foreclose
this basically establish exonerates Yael
Yael narrates anytime it's not it's not
specific to you but um and so what we
were talking about is like what what can
you do with a land acknowledgement that
would be different than that one thing
that came to my mind is we're having
this conversation is so when Lisa
mentioned or maybe Dan mentioned the the
social text issue we had a gathering
here like a year and a half ago or
something like that
Steve pity gave the most incredible
opening remarks to that and to me
provided an a bottle of what a land
acknowledgement could be because what
Steve did I know some folks may have
been here but was to not only to
acknowledge the native peoples and land
and to also to in such way that really
seemed to convey this wasn't something
about a past thing that these are lands
that of course now who knows where those
people are to acknowledge that as a
living relationship but also to go
further and to make connections and this
is getting to you like actually this
does have to do with the question you
just posed so getting to the ways in
which those relations are bound up with
also the relation Gail plays a very
specific role in New Haven in this part
of Connecticut and the ways in which
talking about undocumented people in the
context of this every struggle you know
the forms of like racial terror that
students faculty experience in the
context of the University again not
lemon not exceptional to you but really
the ways in which to draw out the
specificity of place I thought it was a
way to do Al and acknowledgement that
addressed how those in connections how
they actually that sort of the ways that
that there are connections that between
peoples who are differently positioned
but nonetheless subjugated to the forms
of colonization of the capitalist
extraction in ways that do ongoing
intense violence and by acknowledging
the ways in which this place is
structured by those conditions provides
ways that we can see connections between
each other and struggle against those so
to me that was just such a I would say
thank you again Steve for that because
it was such a
a model of how and again can can be just
a moment and continuing to think about
what a land acknowledgment can be
because also land acknowledgments right
should actually be a gesture for its how
do you then return land how do you undo
these conditions right they're not just
land acknowledgments now function most
often as a way to secure property not to
redistribute it and so I think it's
incumbent upon all of us to think along
those lines like think about capacious
ly what a land acknowledgement is land
acknowledgement should not I I think I
actually shouldn't just be about native
peoples it should be about native
peoples as living having specific
relationships the land that we are
wherever we are but also bound up with
other peoples and other forms of
structures of power and dispossession so
with the respect and honor which
resonates unfortunately with the
language around the mascot at the
University of Illinois with shape
respect and honor Indians with I think I
think thinking about what a land
acknowledgement should be as an
accounting to responsibilities of what
to do in relationship to you know
imagining that abolition as an actual
form of decolonization I actually I
appreciated that right you cannot have
the United States as a decolonial
structure it cannot exist in that form
it won't and here's where decolonization
for indigenous peoples it requires a
transformation of our government
structures that have invested in certain
versions of sovereignty anti-blackness
capitalism militarism we are we are
smack in the middle of u.s. Empire in
those forms and thinking about about
other alternatives which is I think
partly why we see in indigenous studies
a turn towards this notion of
relationality right that that is an
actual governance government governance
structure it's it's a it's a mode of
it's a mode of being in relationship
it's a mode of being related to people
and and and then land and water and
non-human and in all its forms but it's
about
it's about alternatives to to to racial
capitalism to Imperial sovereignty to
extraction and to to profit I think in
your remarks Joe to you I just wrote a
note here treaty versus Constitution you
raised the treaty and it's something
I've been thinking about if we take
Indigenous Studies not as indigeneity
and Indigenous Studies not as an
ontological category but as a category
of organization political organization a
social organization or consciousness one
of the things I think it puts on the
table that move is to see the treaty as
the founding document for genre of
document of collective life rather than
the Constitution and what then does that
open up for us to read even rethink
other historical moments so this is also
partly to think again an attempt to
answer what you put on the table like
black reconstruction
what if we read black reconstruction
through the lens of treaties what's
going on with treaty relationships and
black reconstruction in the in the Abu
the brief moment of you know a
possibility of the abolition of slavery
brief moment when the slave stands in
the Sun what if we understand that
historical moment through a lens of
treaty relationships rather than through
the lens of Constitution and reforming
or or abolishing or throwing out a
Constitution so yeah what if a land
acknowledgment was to draw on something
a slogan that has a long history on this
continent honor the treaties that's a
very different kind of approach to take
well I'm aware that it's five so I think
we would like to open it up rather than
me asking you questions maybe people
would like to ask questions ourselves I
know you had a discussion and dance
seminar if there's some of you who want
to continue some of those questions
please please address them to our
speakers now
well while you're thinking of them oh I
have lots of good
how do that
they had several cheats and treaties but
they don't have sovereignty in the
international grid today so how was it
that and some points to issues that the
well communities they have to rights to
send switches and now the proclaims his
rights to be recognized as I'll start
with that last one first in a way
because a lot of Native Nations have
actually tried to enter into common
international to evoke international
sovereignty either with each other which
is one thing that you know I activists
and scholars in the field have called
for like to say we can step outside of
the recognition that states are giving
us to recognize ourselves that this is
the most profound version that our
sovereignty never was diminished it's
can't be taken it can't be given its
inherent to what we are as peoples right
it's but then there's the other side of
this which is back to the United States
is what and here I find money's notion
of counter sovereignty incredibly useful
because part of that counter sovereignty
of the United States enacting its own
sovereignty was through the martial
trilogies that declared American Indian
nations to be domestic dependent that
was an act to absolutely prevent foreign
nations from having in any
ability to make alliances with
indigenous nations at a moment the
United States is trying to build itself
as it started empire yeah so I mean it's
very calculated that moved to to some
house suggests that indigenous peoples
in North America are not part of an
international nation when an
international community when in fact we
actually work and had treaties and then
Chickasaws had treaties with the French
the Spanish the English the Americans
but some of them existing all at the
same time that's a history that we lose
and forget when we start to sort of pull
into a United States formation well and
I would just add that also that mean
that's a project that the u.s. is not
just the Marshall trilogy but a series
of markers throughout the 19th century
whether it's the establishment of the
reservation system in 1851 or especially
with the Indian Appropriations Act in
1871 where the u.s. unilaterally says we
will no longer enter into treaties with
with Native Nations that there's a
series of moves that deliberately seek
to diminish and to naturalize the
diminution of native sovereignty as
something different and less than under
the auspice of the United States the
entire 19th century there's a kind of
kind of series of moves towards that
that that Native Nations never accepted
I mean so you have the Iroquois tohsaka
going to in the League of Nations and
8th in the 1924 along with other people
on the paten behalf of their own nations
lobbying this international forum this
continues to happen continues to happen
up into the present I was just right I'm
working on a piece now where as a series
of nations including the Quinault and
the Standing Rock tribe and the twink
itand Haida basically at the moment that
that Trump withdraw withdraws from the
Paris Accord or do they put together a
statement a joint statement saying
because the u.s. fails in its obligation
to the world for and withdrawing from it
we as sovereign nations make a
declaration of our that we will step up
to this challenge and we expect that the
United Nations will also
solicit and encourage other indigenous
nations to directly have relationship
with the UN in the face of climate
catastrophes so this is an ongoing so
what you with your question in a certain
way there's a great question because
it's it's something that has been
naturalized through very specific work
historically to make it somehow
self-evident when in fact that's what
the work of US Empire is not only it's
it's a how do we define what a nation is
I think that's one of the questions
raised here if you go to the UN General
Assembly
these are nation-states but why are they
you know indigenous in indigenous
organizations can can attend General
Assembly meetings as special interest
groups alongside environmentalists
corporations and other organizations so
why not as members of the General
Assembly and what would that look like
so on the question of D biology
violation yeah really thank you for the
question I've been reading the work of
Elizabeth Armstrong a lot and she poses
this question for North American
feminism where there was a turn to a to
a focus on the subject and asking the
question who was the subject of feminism
how is that subject identified and that
was also a turn away from a focus on
questions of organization which had
existed in North American feminist
politics and thought beforehand so
there's been a turn towards questions of
the subject which I think let's say in a
conversation on settler colonialism
could be like a turn towards an emphasis
on questions of who was a settler who is
who is a native and turn away from
questions of organization maybe a
question from indigenous studies that
have been live for a long time what's a
treaty and what is a treaty relationship
put in place so when I think about D
biology izing race it's about again like
reinf Assizes
organization really emphasizing
consciousness rather than emphasizing
this question of the subject
[Music]
I think about the alignment at about
knowledge network obviously to those in
power relationships will end as anything
to speak a little bit more about in each
of your work about just the state of
being a racialized settler and what
responsibilities complicity this
gentleman's got produces and my price
approach doesn't work
that's a great question thanks I'm sorry
I figured about it because like there's
a part of me that I mean there's a there
is strands of settler colonial studies
and indigenous studies that are trying
to think about racialized settlers or
settlers of color or Asian settler
there's lots of different ways that have
been that this question is being
approached from various places in Hawaii
from Canada from us I think in my work I
wanted I wanted to push against that
tendency just a bit because I wanted to
hold through the category of arriving
the pot like this the the fact that
there there isn't I think there's a way
in which settler of color or racialized
settlers assumes a kind of participation
within settler colonialism that isn't
necessarily always a choice and isn't
always it's not it's not equivalent to
settler so it ends up using whiteness as
a frame to hold everything right and so
I I wanted to use Brathwaite to
understand the middle passage as a
particular way of understanding both the
violence of that that movement that that
forced movement across the Atlantic
right as a way to also have a
possibility of an other kind of
relationship with the new space that
we're in if you're always in a constant
mode of arrival right and I think here's
where it's interesting because
indigenous peoples never get to arrive
and we never get to arrive this is
partly why we never are really present
right we never get to arrive into the
present or even the future which is why
you see a lot of indigenous studies
pushing towards future isms because of
the because of the temporal stack
against us right and so I I think I
appreciate those who want to take
accountability and and call for
understanding how structures late you
know here's where's Patrick Wolf's
framework is useful in that he
acknowledges that settler colonialism is
a structure right which means that
people can be in it in certain ways but
I also want to really for me be careful
about assuming that structure I think is
a self identity or that people identify
in it as settler of color or arrive in
these aren't these to me aren't
identical to right where their
relationships still and
still ways that can be transformed
towards other kinds of relationships
that are more resistant to what
whiteness and white settler settlement
can allow us yeah
Alyosha and Juliana who forgives and I
collaborated on a special issue of
theory an event where we were trying to
theorize this idea colonial unknowing
and what actually sparked that was an
engagement with transit of Empire and
there were several different through
lines a lot of different through lines
that led us to to that set of
conversations that that congealed around
this idea of colonial unknowing and one
was you know it still really bizarre to
me that transitive Empire is not read as
a as a queer text as a queer reading
practice so that these categories of
settler and arriving and native are
actually points of critique and they're
not subject positions right and they
named you know powered normative power
dimensions you know these seductions of
power at play seductions of power of
sovereignty or
ownership there are seductions that will
be you know foreclosed and ripped away
from from from us and so i think part of
the part of this part of this impulse to
read across relations and to read across
fields was driven by that particular
reading of transit of empire but as a
text already been said so well that i
think like the the whole the sort of
debates around settler of color
misconstrues the dynamics of power right
i mean it just it's a way to sort of
create these equivalencies that actually
don't reckon with what exactly
money when Jodi have just said so I mean
I'm not saying that's where your
questions coming from I think your
question really is I mean is an
excellent to speak to what are these
relationships and I think that so often
though there's the response has been
like a Miss reading of Jodi's work to
say somehow she has this tripart schema
and somehow that like these are identity
categories when in fact
that's not what the work does is at both
mano and Julia Jody have just said so
but the constant rien scription of that
I think tells us a lot right I mean
there's a real impulse to turn to those
as identity categories and I
I mean I can't help but think some of
those are is a kind of white supremacist
logic I mean I think that you know there
is also like the identity to talk about
an identity a settler is bizarre to me
right for white folks to like is that
claiming as then like is it a is it an
apology is it a kind of affirmation is
it as opposed to reckoning with the kind
of the histories of which we are
complicit and we are differently
positioned it's just so much more than
that tripartite schema and but I do
think as I said already I think there's
a reason why it keeps recirculating as
just that as these fixed points we were
talking beforehand about the ontological
turn that we're in and thinking about
how a lot of our arguments are hinged
upon how we are understanding ourselves
and then how we position ourselves and
so there's there is this identify this
identificar
in pulse right to locate oneself within
power privilege that come from I think
really sometimes in incredibly important
intellectual traditions from black
feminism to really locate identity
politics intersectionality and and as a
space to speak from right but it ends up
in in this moment as we're watching the
radical right you know reassert its its
dominance we're seeing the other side of
it which is a narcissistic celebration
of power and so I find myself being
uncomfortable with that ontological turn
right I want to I want to I I said to
the class before before this that
there's parts of me this is where I'm a
post colonialist I keep going I keep
holding Gayatri Spivak Scotian about
always being the informant right that
this is this is as it's a it's set up
for us it's the expectation to always be
the person speaking but the
but the trap of that is is her point
which is this when you're speaking
you're no longer subaltern right you are
already encoded into power it's it's
that's actually that the trick of the
subaltern speaking or not speaking right
said earlier question about late futures
and maturity so you know
and you know social reproduction
the eternal nature of an empire how do
we have a word that project of the sort
of conjectural words future honor means
I think the first durable materialism
you know that lake that follows
but it seems a little bit trickier or
potentially to here
okay
well for me the way I understand
conjuncture analysis is precisely to
analyze what are the points of
contradiction in the present and what
are the possible futures so there's
always a possibility in a crisis like
we're living in for capital or the
imperialist of the colonizer to retrench
their power and strengthen their power
and there's that's a that's a strong
likelihood but there's also the
possibility for an opening in another
direction so to me that's precisely the
power of conjuncture analysis or
historical materialism it's a it's a
methodology that actually puts the
possibility of a different future on the
table so you know if I'm working the
19th century in archives the questions
are masking of that archive just for me
personally are driven by my assessment
of the what's happening in the world as
as I go to that archive what's going on
outside as I'm reading these documents
from 1865 the questions I would ask of
it to formations of US colonialism
Alyosha use you describe u.s.
colonialism as continuously failing and
perpetually incomplete and I wonder you
know picking up on this idea of
dialectical materialism to what extent
that converges with an Marxist idea of
contradiction or what does what would
what difference does it make that it's
incomplete and contradictory you don't
use that word contradictory and imposing
well yeah I mean that just okay so um I
hadn't yeah hadn't thought about
thinking of those two things together I
think it makes a lot of sense and in
some ways because it's about sort of
beginning kind of an imminent critique
of something that's take to be taken to
be self-evident I and I guess I could
see the sort of the you know that Marcus
critique is
one that that is structure around
basically how do you understand and
amplify those contradictions right
that's one of the things the critical
theory does and so I could see those
things working together very well in the
sense of like understanding this
geopolitical entity called the United
States that's taken to be self-evident
that taken to have a kind of a solidity
and a coherence that when in fact to
begin to see the constituent parts is in
fact not all lining up that that begins
to be open up possibilities I mean I
guess when I in thinking about that
framing in that in the introduction my
my thought really had to do was almost
more descriptive right like that we if
we actually look at the very conditions
that we imagined to be one way they are
not that and that not being that opens
up possibilities for future in the sense
that if we realize that actually there
that this the thing that we take to be
self-evident permanent whatever it
opened its that we use the term D
familiar ation of defamiliarization at
the beginning I think that's to me
there's maybe there's a connection there
with the Marxist critique Iran
contradictions it seems to me that's the
I mean I don't know I think about
teaching I think about writing one of
the fundamental things I think that we
do is that we draw attention to those
things that seem to be we seem to
understand and say that's isn't what it
is that you thought it was all along
it's that kind of D familiarize ation
that allows kind of few projects of
Futurity of transformation of you know
liberation transfer revolution right
because actually the things that seem to
be so powerful as they are the common
sense that we take to be kind of
monolithic and unalterable is not that
and by beginning to see that we actually
have the possibility to intervene in new
ways Marxist contradiction is only being
between capital and labor that there are
actually different sites of
contradiction if you're
King at settler colonialism racial
slavery overseas Empire and that's part
of the perpetual or completely as I was
understanding well and I think that I
mean when you're asking the question
which is a wonderful question I think
the what may all that eyes think about
in terms of Futurity is the sort of the
radical imagination of future isms right
so like you know whether it's you know
they're like you know for futurism
there's all there's there are multiple
future isms now that I think are about
this possibility of what what kind of
radical imagination can we have in a
context where we're told again and again
that if anything we there is no future
right the world we're in the death
throes of the world that we live in
habit a court I mean that a radical
imagination is more crucial more now
than ever it may not you know it may not
be that kind of ultimate possibly set of
possibilities but actually I think it's
like not being you know if we can have a
radical imagination that's grounded in
an understanding of present conditions
maybe that's a conjunct all analysis
again then that's where we get some more
different and so much of power is shored
up by making sure that we don't see that
at various moments in my next book on
video games tied with the idea of
indigenous pessimism x' as a way to
think about indigenous future isms right
because there's something that's
happening within how indigenous peoples
are both dealing with the reality of I
mean here's where the ongoing is it does
certain work to actually make it a make
it present right it's I appreciate all
the ways you unravel but one of the
things that you know I think indigenous
futurists are saying is that we're
living in Lindsey Nixon's words
Apocalypse Now right that we in in that
we've already gone through the the the
disaster and through that's what
genocide and colonialism were right and
that this we've already it survived that
and so but it's interesting that in the
and the literature's that we're
producing the films it's a it's it's
even more dystopic and yet it's always
speaking to survival and dystopia right
there's a certain
this is where indigenous pessimism gets
and I want intentionally to be in
conversation with afro pessimism right
in this and in part because I think
there's there's there's a critical
difference around indigeneity in the
dialectic with whiteness whiteness
constantly puts itself into the space of
indigeneity in settlement and so it it
prevents it prevents the kind of
negation that afro pessimism is able to
sort of activate because it's already in
negation of the negation because it's
only where whiteness wants to be it it
wants to be the native it's constantly
filling that up in that space that's
that's the whole so indigenous
imaginings of the future have to be able
to to account for that and not replicate
anti blackness in that process thank you
for that for me was so refreshing about
so much what you were saying is your
engagement or what I see that has to
start you kind of love sort of a
separation between what we not
considered native or indigenous studies
and blacks and sort of black studies all
using the black
tradition and so especially in terms of
specifically won't think about ratio
Kapil is on the seller colonialism as
different frameworks but um what this
reminded me too is even thinking about
how these two turns and the intellectual
endeavor we're doing right now
why are themselves historical products
so think you know Rachel clapper doesn't
proceed tellenson and actually it's not
Africa right yes so if they were
thinking about the apartheid state which
is obviously Rachel capitalist but so
what I find amazing is that there's also
districts origin trajectory of that all
of that term all the way from some of
what we think of as far to today we're
just helping us explain just a little
new global order so I just want to say
that comics I think it was it's one of
the first few times I thought this sort
of connection between the scholarship
but also just a historical event started
happening and I just might say I really
appreciate that I can respond to your
non question with a non-answer which I
think that that sort of also the the the
genealogy that you just spoke to in
terms of racial capitalism being you
know within the South African context
within our apartheid South Africa
I feel like in ghent like so there's
there's a way in which you know
attending to the specificity of like the
hearing now is crucial but I also think
that that here and now there's such a
impulse a kind of set of I think that we
oftentimes they cease being located in
the u.s. if we're talking about sort of
like for even for native folks in North
America how different that is than other
contexts I like to talk about African
indigeneity is to talk about you know
what it looks like but across the
hemisphere I think that's so crucial
needs to be part of the conversation as
well and I just just suggested that just
I mean I when you were saying that made
me think about how important it is as
located here to make these broader set
of connections which are fraught I mean
they're it's it's they're not simple
like transpositions of something like
indigeneity is a framework that also
you know and meshed with colonialism but
anyway I thank you for that comment and
that was my actually can help us defend
motorized the present that's part of
what the work is about by really you
know and that puts that puts Futurity on
the table in a different way the present
isn't natural it's not naturally
ordained the president is one particular
possible present among other presents
possible present so that's to me that's
like you know puts Futurity on the table
but to raise South Africa and also then
raises the questions you know how can we
see these in different ways it's
significant that the conversation on
settler colonialism emerges out of the
South African Communist Party in the
struggle against apartheid what is it
that SACP and the leadership the
intellectual leadership of the party was
seeing with apartheid South Africa and
naming something as settler colonialism
that then could be useful for us let's
say if we want to read the work of
someone like Gerald Horne who wants us
to understand the history of this
continent through the lens of class
collaboration again when then what does
that put on the table for us with seeing
Futurity in a different in a different
way
so we're at 5:30 and this has been such
a rich discussion I was just thinking a
panel on settler colonialism and racial
capitalism would not necessarily inspire
us to think about possibility hope
what's available to us the work we have
to do and yet that's precisely what
you've given us a sense of all the work
that we can do to imagine a whole set of
different futures so we're really
grateful for everything you've shared
the way you've modeled collaboration for
us to ratm again for the resources to
bring it here and for your great
questions thank you so much again
[Applause]
[Music]